des départements de gauche refusent on
dit qu'il refuseraiit d'appliquer la loi
et notamment les délais de carence pour
les aides sociales des étrangers est-ce
que pourtant c'est pas le rôle des élus
d'être exemplaires et de respecter la
loi je pense que dans notre histoire je
ça sera un point de basculement cette
loi vraiment hein euh je pense que dans
notre histoire il y a eu d'autres
moments malheureusement assez sombres
quand il y a des points de basculement
comme ça c'est tout à l'honneur de
certains élus de dire non nous ne
pouvons pas accepter quand il y a des
lois qui sont Conz la désobéissance
civile oui en quelque sorte ça fait
partie des démocraties aussi quand une
loi est célérate et thique effectivement
il faut la com dans État de droit où la
loi s'impose à T vous savez la
désobéissence fisile ça fait partie de
l'état de droit aussi et et donc il faut
aussi permettre mais de toute façon
nous-même nous saisissons nous
saisissons le le Conseil constitutionnel
on n'est pas allé jusqu'au bout il faut
aller jusqu'au bout dans le sens où il
faut attendre justement la décision du
Constitutionnel par rapport à censure et
cette loi comme c'est pas une loi le
rôle du président de la République c'est
d'apaiser le pays c'est pas de le cliver
de le diviser je pense que cette loi
profondément on l' vu avec les débats
que nous avons eu Clive ne n'apaise pas
donc ça serait de la responsabilité du
Président de la République quelle que
soit la décision qui sera rendue par le
Conseil constitutionnel d'apaiser et de
revenir sur certaines décisions puisque
lui-même a reconnu lors d'une interview
dont la caution pour les étudiants
étrangers ça n'était pas une bonne
chose